el benceno fue descubierto por el gran
michael faraday en esos tiempos los
químicos podían deducir la estructura
molecular de los compuestos pero no
tenían forma de conocer cuál era la
estructura de puntos exacta así es que
los químicos sabían que el benceno tenía
6 carbonos y 6 hidrógenos pero no tenía
ni idea de cómo estaban enlazados esos
12 átomos había varias propuestas acerca
de cómo era la estructura de puntos del
benceno y la estructura ganadora fue
propuesta por august kekulé quien decía
que el benceno contenía 6 carbonos
acomodados en un anillo con 3 enlaces
dobles y 3 enlaces simples alternados
osea enlace doble enlace simple enlace
doble enlace simple y así la historia
cuenta que a que culé se le ocurrió esta
estructura
una vez que sueño con dos serpientes que
se mordían la cola se dice que fue en
ese momento cuando se le ocurrió que el
estructura
del benceno tenía forma de anillo pero
bueno esta es una estructura de puntos
posible del benceno y en realidad no era
necesario dibujar estos enlaces dobles
justo en estos lugares
resulta que el benceno se encuentra en
resonancia y justo en el próximo vídeo
vamos a ver a fondo esto de la
resonancia del benceno el asunto es que
estos electrones se están cambiando de
lugar todo el tiempo los electrones que
forman los enlaces pin de estos dobles
enlaces
van saltando de carbono en carbono
y entonces la estructura del benceno
también podría ser esta a ver tenemos
aquí nuestro hexágono y podría hacer que
los enlaces dobles estuvieran aquí acá y
acá ok
cualquiera de estas dos estructuras de
que culé son estructuras aceptadas para
el benceno aunque en el mundo real
la estructura del benceno es un híbrido
de estas dos estructuras en un instante
la estructura más parecida a la molécula
es esta estructura y te fijas otra vez
al instante siguiente y la estructura
más parecida es esta otra porque los
electrones están saltando todo el tiempo
entre estos carbonos formando distintos
enlaces pib por eso es que muchos
químicos prefieren representar al
benceno de esta otra forma tenemos aquí
6 carbonos en un anillo
un círculo en el centro que representa
la deslocalización de esos 6 electrones
que forman los enlaces pero tal vez esta
sea una forma muy floja de representar
al benceno se llama el círculo de
robinson por el gran químico orgánico
sintético ser robert robinson algunas
veces se usa el círculo de robinson y
otras veces se utiliza el anillo ve que
cool si se quiere hablar de algún
mecanismo de reacción del benceno se usa
siempre el anillo de que [ __ ] ahora
veamos cómo se llaman algunos derivados
del benceno aquí tenemos a un benceno
con un grupo metilo entonces podríamos
llamarle
me til
ven seno pero casi nadie le llama metil
benceno generalmente le llaman tolueno
todo lo que no está es una molécula tan
común en la química orgánica que tolueno
es un nombre aceptado en el sistema upac
pero bueno en este ejemplo tenemos
únicamente un substituyen t un grupo
metilo que tiene únicamente un carbono y
este anillo de benceno tiene 6 carbonos
pero qué pasaría si nuestro grupo al
kilo tuvieran más carbonos que el anillo
vence mico que es justo la situación de
esta molécula a ver cuántos carbonos
tiene este grupo al kilo tiene 12
4 5 6 7 carbonos en este caso como el
grupo alquilo tiene más carbonos del
benceno entonces vamos a llamarlo un
arcano y vamos a poner al benceno como
un substituyen t un arcano con 7
carbonos es un eta no
y tenemos un anillo vencen y ccoo en el
carbono número 4 y cuando tenemos un
anillo vencen y ccoo como un sustituyen
te lo llamamos un grupo fenil o así es
que aquí lo que tenemos es un cuatro
fenil de 1000 de que tenemos este anillo
vencen y ccoo en el carbono 4 y por esta
cadena eta no
este es el nombre de acuerdo al sistema
upac de esta molécula ahora veamos otros
derivados del benceno con un sustituye
ente con un solo grupo funcional sobre
el anillo vencen y ccoo todos estos son
benceno c'mon o sustituidos muy famosos
y como son tan famosos sus nombres
coloquiales fueron aceptados en el
sistema de nomenclatura y iupac y ahora
les tenemos que llamar fenol y estireno
annalynne a annie sol acepto fenol y
bueno estos dos ya tienen nombres un
poquito más lógicos son el bne salde y 2
el ácido benzoico pero estos son los
nombres coloquiales que han sido
aceptados por el sistema upac porque son
demasiado famosos y están demasiado
arraigados en la química orgánica
entonces un entonces un anillo vencen y
ccoo con un grupo funcional o h
se llama fenol y vamos a usar ese nombre
cuando estamos nombrando otros derivados
del benceno que tengan un grupo
funcional o h
así es que acuérdate muy bien de su
nombre por acá tenemos al ven sal de
ebro que es un anillo vencen y ccoo que
tiene como grupo funcional a un aldehído
y es muy famoso porque huele a almendras
entonces huele muy bien y bueno de hecho
por ese tipo de cosas porque algunos de
estos compuestos aromáticos huelen muy
bien por eso les empezaron a llamar
compuestos aromáticos pero no todos los
compuestos aromáticos huelen bien se les
empezó a llamar así por su olor pero más
adelante vamos a ver qué significa eso
de ser aromático para los químicos
por acá tenemos al ácido benzoico que es
un anillo vencen y ccoo con un grupo car
box y lo y bueno aquí tenemos el
estireno la annalynne a él a mi sol
la hace toffee nona y es muy importante
que le pongas pausa al vídeo y trato de
recordar cada uno de estos porque
resulta que estos son 7 de los derivados
del benceno más famosos y más comunes y
los utilizamos muchísimo siempre que le
estamos poniendo nombres a cualquier
otro derivado del benceno así es que
aprende de los de memoria ya le pusiste
pausa bueno estos eran puros vencen los
monos sustituidos ahora vamos a ver
benceno y sustituidos esta molécula
tiene dos grupos metidos en este anillo
vencen y ccoo entonces tiene un grupo
metilo en el carbono 1 y en el carbono 2
así es que podríamos llamarle 1/2
dimetil
y metil benceno
ven
seno sin embargo cuando tenemos un
benceno con dos grupos metilo le
llamamos chileno
no en realidad estas tres moléculas son
chilenos todos los anillos vencen y
cause que tengan dos grupos metilo si
son chilenos así es que tenemos que
distinguir a un chileno de otro y bueno
lo que hacemos es que cuando tenemos dos
grupos metilo juntos uno inmediatamente
al lado del otro esta relación de estar
justo al lado se llama [ __ ] entonces
esta molécula también se llama corto
[ __ ] chileno y algunas veces lo
acortamos y dejamos únicamente una o y
entonces se llama o chileno y eso
también está muy bien de acuerdo para
que esta otra molécula como acabamos de
decir también se llama chileno pero como
puedes ver los grupos metilo se están un
poco más separados y cuando tenemos dos
grupos funcionales separados por un
carbono o sea que podríamos decir que
están a una distancia de un carbono
decimos que la relación espacial entre
estos dos grupos funcionales es de tipo
meta y entonces la molécula se llama
meta
meta chileno o si lo habré veamos es
simplemente una m chileno claro que
también sería bueno escribir la
anotación de este estilo más parecido a
lo que hemos hecho con el resto de los
compuestos orgánicos y entonces este
grupo metilo está en el carbono 1 esto
es el carbono 2 y este es el carbono 3
así es que tenemos grupos metidos en los
carbonos 1 y 3 y entonces se llama 13
dimetil dimetil benceno ven
y bueno ya llegamos al último de los
chilenos cualquiera de los dos puede ser
el carbono número uno y después tenemos
dos tres cuatro así es que tenemos dos
grupos metidos en los carbonos 1 y 4
entonces es un 14 dimetil dimetil
benceno benceno pero la mayoría de las
personas le llamaría chileno o bueno tal
vez le llamaría chileno pero se escriben
igual en este caso los grupos
funcionales están completamente en
posiciones opuestas del otro lado del
benceno y a esta relación espacial se le
llama para entonces esta molécula es
de que los met y los están en posiciones
opuestas y después chileno y pleno ahora
veamos otros ejemplos deben ser
substituidos y justo aquí vamos a
utilizar los nombres de algunos de esos
siete derivados del benceno de los que
te dije que le pusieras pausa al inicio
de este vídeo y que te aprendiera sus
nombres así es que vamos a ver qué tan
buena memoria tienes esta molécula esta
de aquí a ver cómo se llama esta
molécula es un freno la fe no entonces
podemos decir de una vez que esta
molécula es un freno en cuanto al bromo
tenemos dos opciones una es numerar a
este benceno y tenemos que empezar la
numeración por aquí porque estamos
diciendo que esta molécula es un phenom
y entonces este es el carbono 12
4 5 y 6 y el bromo está en el carbono
número 4 entonces podríamos poner 40
fenol y ese es un nombre perfectamente
aceptado por el grupo iupac o podríamos
usar el sistema o mp&mp que estábamos
utilizando aquí con el gileno cuando
tenemos dos grupos funcionales en
extremos opuestos del anillo vencen y
ccoo como aquí les llamamos
para así es que esta molécula también se
puede llamar para
bromo fenol
y también es un nombre perfectamente
aceptado por el sistema upac o podemos
abreviar esta palabra para dejar
simplemente una p ahora vamos con este
otro benceno de sustituido podemos ver
que éste
es un ácido benzoico otro de los siete
derivados que tenemos que memorizar así
es que si todavía no te acuerdas de los
nombres ponle pausa y regresa al inicio
del vídeo y aprende de los este es un
ácido ácido benzoico
y ahora solo hay que identificar este
otro sustituye ente que es un grupo
funcional nitro siempre siempre
empezamos a numerar desde aquí que es el
carbono que tiene este grupo funcional
que le da el nombre característico de
esta molécula y también escogemos el
sentido de la numeración de tal forma
que los otros sustituye entes tengan el
número de carbono más pequeño entonces
nos toca este sentido así es que este es
el carbono número 2 y este es el carbono
número 3 entonces el grupo nitro está en
el carbono número 3 por lo que esta
molécula se llama ácido 3 litro
nitro benzoico ven
o también podría usar la notación o mp y
fijarme que aquí entre este aldehído y
este nitro hay una relación espacial
meta porque hay un solo carbono entre
estos dos grupos funcionales y entonces
decir que esta molécula se llama ácido
ha sido meta
meta litro
litro benzoico
ven
soy como ha sido meta nitro benzoico o
también podríamos decir que se llama
ácido m nitro benzoico pero bueno ahora
veamos vencen los polis sustituidos
como estos que resultan ser los ejemplos
más famosos que podríamos llegar a ver y
otra vez vamos a buscar un benceno mono
substituido y vamos a escoger a este de
aquí y otra vez si estamos con uno de
esos compuestos que se supone que ya
sabes cómo se llaman aquí lo que tenemos
es un ben sal de ido
d
sal
y utilizamos este en lugar de utilizar
este de aquí porque los aldehídos tienen
prioridad sobre los alcoholes entonces
tenemos que borrar esto y bueno el
aldehído tiene preferencia entonces
empezamos la enumeración por aquí 2 3
4 y nos fuimos en este sentido para que
todos los sustituyen test tengan el
menor número de carbono posible ahora en
el carbono número 3 tenemos un grupo
éter y cuando tenemos que un grupo éter
es un substituyen t le llamamos med occ
sí entonces esto es un 3
me tocó i vents aldehído y en el carbono
4 tenemos este grupo h que es un alcohol
y si tenemos que un grupo h es un
substituyen t entonces les llamamos
grupo hidroxilo así es que tenemos por
aquí 4
pero si tres métodos y pensar de ido
este es el nombre oficial de acuerdo al
sistema de nomenclatura iupac pero
resulta que es un nombre coloquial
vainilla y vainilla mira nada más las
prácticas de laboratorio que tienen 4
hidroxi tres métodos i vents aldehído
suelen empezar oliendo muy bien pero
bueno vamos con el último de los
derivados de benceno que vamos a ver en
este vídeo pero vamos a hacer un poquito
pequeño a este nombre
buscamos por aquí un benceno mono
sustituido con mayor prioridad y este es
este de aquí
qué es el tolueno todo bueno entonces
esto tiene que ser el carbono número uno
y realmente no importa en qué sentido no
veremos así es que este es el dos
456 solo no importa en este caso porque
tenemos grupos funcionales acomodados de
forma simétrica
pero entonces notamos que en el carbono
2 en el carbono 4 y en el carbono 6
tenemos tres grupos micros y esta
molécula también es súper famosa y super
importante pero bueno el nombre iupac es
three micro nitro tolueno y bueno estas
tres letras deberían de ir en minúscula
pero las dejé en mayúsculas como una
pista bueno el caso es que este es un
compuesto tan famoso que casi nunca se
le llama 246 trinitrotolueno casi todo
el mundo y algunas caricaturas lo
conocen como t n de que es un explosivo
bastante famoso y bueno se llama así
tnt justo por las iniciales de
trinitrotolueno en fin me parece que
esta es una muy buena introducción a
cómo se llaman las moléculas que tienen
benceno en algún lugar de su estructura